I put that almond milk in mine dude
almond milk that's crazy man
almond milk when you think about it I
can't believe that they're milking
almonds okay what you know I think about
you know they got vegans and vegetarians
and all of that you know uh whatever
these people are who ever is you know
from Vietnam or whatever but I don't you
know and I want to be supportive but
dude there we all are milk and almonds
they have almond milk
dude when I first of all when I was
young they I remember they had almond
joy remember almond joy almonds was
having fun almonds were just laying on
coconut just pouring they had chocolate
all over their bodies they had two of
them on the coconut they had a little
amigo up there a little almond ego and
then a couple years ago they started
having almond butter and I'm like whoa
dang what did they do what did they do
to deserve this they'd beaten them up
and buttering them up and you can
picture it if you want in your head and
I don't like to picture that kind of
stuff but you could picture it but your
almonds getting just smashed into each
other and buttered and then now they got
almond milk now they have almond milk
and you even can you even imagine that
how are you gonna milk and almond and
call yourself a decent person who's
doing this I didn't even know almonds
had glands we're taking what are they
doing
can you imagine getting up early and
getting a couple almonds out and putting
a little bucket between them and just
being nasty this is God you know this
has got to stop
I don't like a lot of the you know I
don't know man I don't know I mean I've
done soba I've done a bunch of shady
[__] okay I'll admit that
you know I've lied to people and I've
definitely I buried a bunch of people's
[__] furniture one time and I lied to
him about it but I've never I've never
done anything pervert like that to a
damn nut so if you out there milk and
almonds why don't you ask yourself who
you are I mean hell I'd rather eat I'd
rather have me I'd rather eat meat and
be a regular human and then be some just
creepy-crawler out there just you know
with these fingers out just [__]
warming his fingers up searching an
almond for a damn gland yeah ma'am very
sad very sad